and our shutout tonight for an
investigative reporter in South Carolina
who took on one of the state's most
powerful groups it's 46 County sheriff's
as in most states it's an elective
office and the local sheriff's in South
Carolina rarely get much attention it
was a tip to a local investigative
reporter that led this summer to prison
time for powerful South Carolina
prosecutor Dan Johnson reporter Tony
bartoleme of the Post and Courier in
Charleston South Carolina found the
evidence he needed for his story on the
prosecutor in Johnson's own expense
reports nobody looked at him yet
nobody had sifted through them so I got
a hold of them and started looking
through them and a bunch of things just
immediately about including a $173
override in Minneapolis where bartoleme
used to live I thought you know I bet he
went to Prince's house on the Publix
dime and lo and behold that's exactly
what he did and during that trip he also
- spent money on a major league baseball
game the twins and from there we started
looking into other things like trips to
the Galapagos Islands
there's class playing trips to all over
the country and and things like that
bartoleme who is the senior reporter on
the post and couriers investigative team
says they decided to expand their probe
into all official expense reports so we
thought what are other islands of
government in South Carolina that exist
on their own without much scrutiny and
Sheriff's immediately came to mind and
so we basically we saw every spending
record we could get from every county in
the state all 46 counties suspended
greenville county sheriff will lewis is
facing more charges tonight
among those highlighted by Barlow me was
sheriff will Lewis of Greenville County
now facing criminal charges that he was
using public money to carry on a sexual
relationship with an employee who has
now claimed she was raped he has denied
the charges
her claims her allegations that
basically forced her to have sex forced
her to do other things in and used that
fear of termination losing her job as a
as a cudgel next was the sheriff of
Florence County people who live in the
area are speaking out after the man they
elected sheriff Kenny Boone was arrested
and charged with embezzlement and
misconduct in office Sheriff Kenny Boone
is also now facing state charges as a
result of Barb amis reporting he too has
pleaded not guilty again it was all
these these these sort of questionable
expenses for personal gain the most
serious charges came following
Bartleby's story on sheriff alex
Underwood Underwood had a pattern of
misbehavior ranging from assaults he'd
assaulted a couple of fire chiefs at a
traffic stop and also a man was live
streaming traffic wreck as the man was
streaming his video on Facebook sheriff
Underwood is seen approaching him and
can be heard challenging him there was a
scuffle essentially Underwood and his
deputies threw the guy in jail cooked up
a bunch of bogus charges and then tried
to cover up when they FBI began
investigate sheriff Underwood is now
under federal indictment he has pleaded
not guilty to the charges when we put it
all together we produced you know a very
large package of stories that really and
captured the scope and significance of
and history of why sheriff's have gotten
into trouble
Bartleby says his editors no such
investigative reporting takes time and
money but that they have decided it is
the only way local newspapers can
survive in the past few years we've
analyzed the data and we've found that
people are more likely to subscribe to
stories that are done with depth
and quality we found that the sheriff
story for instance generated the most
subscriptions of any story last year or
earlier this year on a local level it's
really the only way we'll be able to
survive and we are finding that
investigative journalism though it's
expensive is what keeps people reading
so our shout-out tonight for Tony Marla
me and his editors demonstrating how
investigative reporting can do good and
do well on a personal note Tony's father
Joe was one of broadcast journalism is
great and I was fortunate enough to have
worked for him when I first started my
career at NBC News
nice to see Tony's carry on the
tradition of journalism with an impact
that's our program for tonight thanks
for joining us we'll see you back here
next week